véronique pau et présidente et
directrice générale des manufacturiers
et exportateurs du québec bonsoir
bonsoir vous avez eu des échanges avec
le canadien national n'est ce pas cet
après midi consacré à l'or en organisant
un appel avec plusieurs de nos membres
au québec mais à travers le canada aussi
qui sont des clients pour leur permettre
de poser des questions par rapport à
l'état de la situation
alors les représentants du ciel ont
rapporté un peu l'état de la situation
le nombre de grévistes en place en poste
le nombre de jours depuis quand la durée
de la grève à ce jour ils ont aussi
mentionné que 10 % des cadres ont eu la
formation pour être capable de conduire
certains trains dont qui ont dégagé les
voies et se prépare pour quand la grève
va se terminer qu'ils pourront reprendre
mais je voudrais que l'appel surtout été
l'opportunité pour nos membres de poser
des questions et on sent beaucoup de
préoccupations beaucoup à la
présentation
alors les entreprises ont parfois des
produits ou des marchandises qui sont
pris dans des wagons ou dans les cours
ils n'y ont pas nécessairement accès on
a des entreprises qui importent des
produits des états unis donc qui n'ont
pas accès à des fournitures ou des
composantes leur permettant de fabriquer
leurs produits
des gens dans l'agroalimentaire qui ont
des produits réfrigérés qui sont aussi
prix dans cette problématique là alors
les gens se disent combien de temps ce
que ça va durer combien temps que le
gouvernement va laisser durer cette
situation laisse qu'on est ce qu on
commence déjà à mesurer des pertes
absolument alors on a des seins nus
membres qui ne mentionnait son
entreprise que 1500 employés qui chiffre
à 1 million par jour ses pertes dans ce
contexte elle a donc le secteur c'est
dans le secteur n'en secteur de la part
dans le secteur de la construction de la
construction mais quelle est la
proportion de marchandises ou de
fourniture de veau mort brute qui
circule présentement par trait au canada
alors elle s'est quand même facturier
représente 50% du volume et où des
wagons si vous le voulez du cn alors
c'est clair que c'est là un impact
significatif pour l'enfant des
entreprises qui l'utilisent
on va regarder quelques chiffres sur le
transport en 2018 de transport
ferroviaire de frais 331 millions 700
mille tonnes de fraises c'était une
hausse de 6% par rapport à l'année
précédente
et voyez les secteurs qui représentent
en bonne partie s'étonne de frais le
charbon le fret conteneurisé les
conteneurs bien sûr
le grain les produits du bois les
produits chimiques les produits
pétroliers excluant les pour le pétrole
brut mais le pétrole brut partie bien
sûr des secteurs qui sont transportés
par train et la potasse chez vous quels
sont les secteurs particulièrement
affectées alors on parle le secteur de
la construction de l'agroalimentaire
c'est vraiment tous les secteurs qui
sont représentés en a eu au téléphone 75
entreprises à travers le canada
tous les secteurs d'activité sont
concernés et des fois c'est humain mais
parfois c'est leurs fournisseurs qui
sont touchés par le train et salah un
impact ultime ans pour eux et c'est
pourquoi nos membres souhaitent
ardemment que le ministre garneau la
ministre a tiqué la nouvelle ministre du
travail puisse plus proposé exiger un
arbitrage exécutoire pour les deux
parties c'est ce qui est demandé c'est
paula loi spéciale qui est demandé c'est
un arbitrage exécutoire donc salle
implique les travailleurs doivent
retourner au travail que les deux
parties doivent s'entendre sur un
arbitre et que sa décision devient
exécutoire à ce moment là mais les teams
stories ont dit clairement qu'ils
voulaient pas d'être absolument
absolument
alors c'est peut-être la loi spéciale
que sa propre douleur dans tous les cas
ce que les manufacturiers souhaite c'est
que l'on puisse reprendre le transport
le plus rapidement possible ça devient
concevable de penser que cette grève
l'opus se poursuivre encore une semaine
deux semaines trois semaines ce sont des
entreprises qui vont devoir fermer des
lignes de production qui ne pourront pas
répondre à la demande
ultime ans avoir un impact sur
l'ensemble de l'économie québécoise et
canadien je le dis à d'autres moyens de
transport on peut il ya les voies
maritimes bien sûr il ya les camions il
ya les camions alors on sait que le
réseau est déjà très surchargé pénurie
de main d'oeuvre c'est très difficile de
trouver des camionneurs des chauffeurs
alors certains et certaines entreprises
par exemple dans l'agroalimentaire sont
privilégiés ont réussi à trouver des
transporteurs mais ce n'est pas la
portée de tous et lorsqu'on parle de
commerce interprovincial ou vers les
états unis
le transport maritime n'est pas tout à
fait
un véhicule souhaité et abordable non
plus merci beaucoup madame crocs pour
ces indications ce soir on suit bien sûr
de près ce qui se passe compte tenu de
l'importance du secteur ferroviaire
pendant la femme de l'économie
canadienne véronic pour des
manufacturiers et exportateurs du québec
merci merci à vous